[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin hallo und guten Abend im
Studio mit mir ist Katja Stresow später
mit großem Tennis und Fußball stimmt
schönen guten Abend und wir blicken
gemeinsam auf die Themen der Sendung
AFD mit Rückenwind in den derzeit hohen
Umfragewerten sieht der Parteitag den
Auftrag zur Regierungsbeteiligung
dramatisches Ladensterben in deutschen
Innenstädten besonders im Osten machen
viele Geschäfte dicht die Gründe
vielfältig
Genie und Provokateur mit 96 Jahren
stirbt der Schriftsteller Martin Walser
in seiner Heimat am Bodensee
[Musik]
die AFD weiß um ihre aktuell hohen
Zustimmungswerte und tritt auch
dementsprechend auf auf ihrem Parteitag
in Magdeburg immer lauter formulieren
die Rechtspopulisten einen
regierungsanspruch und sorgen damit auch
für aufgeregte Debatten die bei der CDU
Europa politisch kommen widersprüchliche
Signale aus der Partei mehr von Thomas
Reichert
die Gunst in den Umfragen sorgt bei der
AFD für zweierlei erstens das Gefühl im
Moment alles richtig zu machen zweitens
die Forderung an die Union Bündnisse mit
der AFD einzugehen den Teilen
rechtsextreme Partei will mitregieren
wer Brandmauern baut lieber Herr Merz
bleibt ein Gefangener grüner Ideologie
und das merken immer mehr Menschen in
diesem Land
im Saal hat die Partei ihre eigenen
Mauern gebaut doppelte Absperrbänder
schirmen die Presse ab so macht das nur
die AFD eine Brandmauer gegen die AFD
fordern draußen stattdessen die Omas
gegen Rechts während dann Himmel über
Magdeburg ein protestflugzeug seine
Kreise zieht
die Parteien nimmt nun die nächsten
Wahlen in den Blick unter anderem die
Europawahl im kommenden Jahr im
Leitantrag zu dieser Wahl will die
parteiga die Auflösung der EU angeblich
ein Versehen schließlich kann die AFD
nicht für alle 27 Mitgliedstaaten der EU
entscheiden es war tatsächlich nie
vorgesehen die EU aufzulösen das war ein
Fehler der passieren kann sollte nicht
passieren aber es macht keinen Sinn die
EU aufzulösen wenn man austreten will
denn den EU-Austritt den wollen Sie
wirklich scharfe Kritik der
Parteivorsitzender der deutschen Ukraine
Politik ein Waffenlieferungen für Kiew
und dann Sanktionen gegen Moskau
ansteckt neutral zu vermitteln hat die
ampelregierung einseitig Stellung für
den Westen bezogen sie missachtet die
Sicherheitsinteressen Russlands und tut
so als wäre der Krieg 2022 aus heiterem
Himmel ausgebrochen kein Wort von
koopalle dazu dass es Russland war dass
die Ukraine angegriffen hat die
koffersitzende Denkweise sogar über eine
afd-kanzlerkandidatur nach es gibt
verschiedene Kanzlerkandidaten die sich
das auch vorstellen können die ich auch
für qualifiziert halte und das wird dann
eben nächstes Jahr sondiert die AFD
sieht sich auf den Weg nach oben
zentrale Forderungen der Partei wie eine
nato-austritt oder ein Ende des Euro
aber lehnt eine Mehrheit der Deutschen
laut Umfragen nach wie vor ab
Nicole Dieckmann verfolgt den Parteitag
in Magdeburg für uns Nicole die AFD will
mitregieren aber keiner mit ihr was
bietet die Partei an
die AFD setzt quasi auf Masse der
einhellige Tenor hier heute in den Reden
ist wir wollen dermaßen stark bei Wahlen
vor allem kommen des Jahr bei den
Landtagswahlen im Osten abschneiden dass
die anderen Parteien gar nicht mehr an
uns vorbeikommen denn dann so jedenfalls
die Lebensart hier müssen die sich nach
der AFD richten und nicht umgekehrt dass
das natürlich ein theoretisches
Konstrukt ist weiß man auch hier und
deshalb baut man rhetorisch
vorsichtshalber schon mal vor man sagt
hier sollten die anderen Parteien
Koalitionen um die AFD herumschmieden um
sie auszuschließen würde das
Politikverdrossenheit fördern und der
AFD langfristig noch mehr Wähler in die
Arme treiben die Partei ist berauscht
von ihrem aktuellen Höhenflug in den
Umfragen das die anderen Parteien nicht
mit ihr zusammenarbeiten wollen und
damit eine Mehrheit der Wähler hinter
sich haben das tut man hier als ein
Problem ab dass sich lösen lässt Nicole
vielen Dank nach Magdeburg und mehr
afd-parteitag auch ab 19.30 Uhr bei den
Kollegen von heute live in unserer heute
App und auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
können Sie das dann verfolgen
17 Monate schon verteidigt sich die
Ukraine gegen den russischen
Angriffskrieg und seit knapp zwei
Monaten versucht Kiew mit einer
Gegenoffensive besetzte Gebiete
zurückzuerobern es ist ein harter ein
verlustreicher Abnutzungskampf Präsident
silensky spricht jetzt von Fortschritten
seine Truppen haben offenbar südlich von
saporicia russische Linien durchbrochen
mehr von Luton Linus
Ehre der Ukraine Ehre den Helden rufen
Sie und feiern die Befreiung des Dorfes
darum majorski diese Aufnahmen des
ukrainischen Militärs sollen belegen was
Moskau bestreitet Meter für Meter haben
die Truppen trotz vieler Minenfelder und
heftigen Beschuss durch russische
Artillerie einen wichtigen Geländegewinn
erzielt seit kieft hingegenangriff
begann wurden nur wenige Gebiete
zurückerobert ihr weiß markiert staro
majorsk und robotine sollen befreit
worden sein von hier aus könnte es
weitergehen Richtung militopol wenn man
das vergleicht mit dem Beginn der
ukrainischen Offensive dann hat die
Ukraine in den letzten sieben Wochen
zwölf Kilometer zurückgelegt das klingt
jetzt erstmal nicht so beeindruckend
aber das sind natürlich Minenfelder in
offenem Gelände wo jede Bewegung sofort
gesehen wird das ist schon jetzt ein
signifikanter Fortschritt von auf
majorst ist vor allem verbrannte Erde
geblieben es ist ein teuer erkaufter
Triumph mit großen Verlusten an
Menschenleben bis zu 20 Prozent des
eingesetzten kriegsgeräts sind
beschädigt oder zerstört sagen Experten
die russischen Verteidigungslinien und
Minenfelder sind nur schwer zu
überwinden von dem erwähnten Ort ist bis
zum Meer sind es noch 115 km also das
sieht daran erkennt man schon das wird
jetzt nicht schnell gehen da werden auch
keine Wunder passieren aber man kann
glaube ich sagen für die Ukraine die
Richtung stimmt auf die minenräume kommt
es derzeit an erst wenn sie mit ihrer
gefährlichen Arbeit fertig sind können
die Panzer vorrücken und Gebiete
zurückerobern
der brennende Auto Frachter in der
Nordsee soll nach Medienberichten nicht
25 sondern knapp 500 E-Autos geladen
haben das könnte auch die Bergung
erschweren weil deren Batterien schwer
zu löschen sind laut Küstenwache hat das
Feuer etwas nachgelassen
Bergungsexperten konnten das Schiff kurz
betreten und eine neue schleppverbindung
installieren sollte der Frachter Kentern
oder untergehen droht eine
Umweltkatastrophe eine Umweltkatastrophe
droht auch im Roten Meer mit dem
Unterschied dass die Gefahr hier seit
Jahren bekannt ist vor der Küste Jemens
liegt eine tickende Zeitbombe der marode
super Tanker die fsoyver seit 2015 wurde
sie wegen des Bürgerkrieges nicht mehr
gewartet rostet quasi vor sich hin mit
mehr als einer Million Barrel Öl an Bord
die werden jetzt abgepumpt in einer
heiklen bergungsmission wie gollini atai
uns zeigt
der Beginn einer von den Vereinten
Nationen mühsam vorbereiteten
Rettungsaktion die einfache aussieht als
sie ist das Abpumpen von mehr als einer
Million Barrel jemenitische Öl von einem
Schiff aufs andere unterstehter
explosionsgefahr
wegen des Bürgerkrieges im Jemen rotete
die fsu-surfer über Jahre vor sich hin
Salzwasser drang in den Maschinenraum
der Rost nagt am Schiff
der super-tanker liegt nicht weit
entfernt von geschützten Inselketten
bekannt für ihre Artenvielfalt ein
Ölteppich würde Mangroven und
korallengefährden und die Meerwasser in
Salzung für fast 2 Millionen Menschen
eine der wichtigsten Routen der
Weltwirtschaft wäre unterbrochen
im Hafen von hordeder sind die Fische
froh über die Bergung eine Ölkatastrophe
hätte sie in den Ruin getrieben nicht
nur das humanitäre Hilfsgüter auf die
Millionen Menschen hier nach acht Jahren
Bürgerkrieg angewiesen sind könnten
nicht mehr geliefert werden
ein ölig würde die Fischarten hier
vernichten die Korallenriffe zerstören
nicht nur hier bei uns
zwei Jahre Verhandlungen brauchte es und
einen brüchigen Waffenstillstand bis
diese Rettungsaktion der Vereinten
Nationen beginnen konnte aber noch immer
fehlen den UN 21 Millionen Dollar um den
Tanker zu entsorgen sagt der
Verantwortliche der Bergungsaktion
mein Appell auch weiterhin bleibt
an Regierungen aber auch an Unternehmen
und ich sage immer wieder vor allem die
Ölung Gasindustrie die
Schifffahrtsindustrie das sind Sektoren
für die wir hier auch letztlich tätig
sind denn das sind ihre Weltmärkte des
in ihrer Schifffahrtsrouten das sind
ihre
Einkommensmöglichkeiten
klappt die Operation wollen die UN mit
den Kriegsparteien klären wem das
gesicherte Öl gehört
noch nie war Deutschland so hoch
verschuldet wie 2022 verantwortlich
dafür auch die Kosten zur Bewältigung
der corona-pandemie und der Energiekrise
unterm Strich standen Bund Länder
Gemeinden und die Sozialversicherung mit
insgesamt
2368 Milliarden Euro in der Kreide ein
Plus von zwei Prozent zum Vorjahr so
dass Statistische Bundesamt umgerechnet
hätte damit jeder Bürger
28.164 Euro Schulden
ja vieles ist wieder teurer geworden in
Deutschland immerhin im Juli hat sich
die Inflation etwas abgeschwächt zur
besseren Einordnung ein Blick zurück
juli 21 da lag die Preissteigerung noch
bei 3,7% im Vergleich zum Vorjahresmonat
dann ging es deutlich hoch bis auf 8,8 %
im vergangenen Herbst seit Januar
verlangsamt sich die Preissteigerung
wieder und liegt jetzt nach vorläufiger
Schätzung noch bei 6,2% und wieder sind
vor allem Lebensmittel
überdurchschnittlich teurer geworden
also immer noch über 6% Inflation in
Deutschland Valerie Haller in Frankfurt
an der Börse warum schaffen es andere
europäische Länder die Inflationsrate
schneller zu drücken als Deutschland
also das zeigt ja insgesamt ganz gut wie
heterogen Europa ist was auch daran
liegt dass es natürlich keine
einheitliche Wirtschaftspolitik gibt
jedes Land ist anders mit den
Herausforderungen der stark gestiegenen
Energiepreise umgegangen und das wirkt
sich massiv auf die Inflation in den
jeweiligen Ländern aus Spanien
beispielsweise hat viel getan um die
Bürger zu entlasten mit Steuersenkungen
mietdeckel Tankrabatt und ähnliches die
Energiepreise liegen dort auch dank
erneuerbarer Energien natürlich deutlich
niedriger als in Deutschland nicht nur
in Spanien auch in Belgien zahlen die
Menschen weniger für Energie die
Inflationsrate entsprechend niedrig
gleiches gilt für Griechenland ganz
anders in Italien Lettland und Estland
wo es den Regierungen nicht gelang die
Energiepreise zu drücken selten waren
die Teuerungsraten in Europa so
unterschiedlich wie aktuell dass sie in
Deutschland bald wieder nachhaltig
sinken davon ist wohl erstmal nicht
auszugehen laut Ifo-Institut rechnen
Unternehmen vor allem im Einzel und auch
weiter im Lebensmittelhandel mit
Teuerungen die Inflation hält sich ein
hartnäckig und das ist kein gutes
Vorzeichen für eine rasche
Konjunkturerholung in Deutschland
Valerie vielen Dank und Grüße nach
Frankfurt ja auch der Einzelhandel hat
zu kämpfen der Handelsverband
Deutschland schätzt dass allein in
diesem Jahr 9000 Geschäfte schließen
müssen auch viele Lebensmittel Läden
geben auch gerade im kleineren Orten und
im ländlichen Raum was das für die
Menschen bedeutet zeigt Stefan Kelch er
war in Kurven Saales in Sachsen
das 1.000 seelenstädtchen Kochen sales
verliert seinen Lebensmittelpunkt den
Konsum sein Ende ist beschlossene Sache
es gelingt uns schon seit vielen Jahren
nicht mehr die Filiale wirtschaftlich zu
betreiben mehr noch die Verluste sind
mittlerweile im koordinale so hoch dass
das Ergebnis des gesamten Unternehmens
dadurch gefährdet wird
verärgert sind die Menschen weil sie von
dieser Entscheidung überrascht wurden
wir haben jetzt nicht uns damit
beschäftigt im Rathaus dass der Konsum
irgendwie schließen könnte es gab
zumindest bei uns keinerlei Anzeichen in
der Richtung die Regale weitgehend
ausgeräumt die Einwohner müssen sich
künftig acht Kilometer entfernt
versorgen das ist schön vor allen Dingen
vor die älteren Menschen die überhaupt
keine Möglichkeit haben was einzukaufen
ne es gibt hier keine ausreichende
Busverbindung wo sollen die hin es hat
nicht jeder Familie im Ort eigentlich
auf gut deutsch tut
oren sah alles eine alte Töpfer statt
mit dem Thema Niedergang bestens
vertraut von 1-14 Töpfereien gibt es
noch zwei der Konsum der ist nur der
letzte Laden der geht
wir hatten einen Schuhladen wir hatten
ein Schreibwarenladen wir hatten im Ort
Gaststätten dann ist die
Raiffeisenbank und die Sparkassen
weggegangen danach folgte der Apotheke
und jetzt ist es im Prinzip der Konsum
mit ihm verschwindet nun das Leben aus
der Innenstadt wenn der Konsum schließt
schließt eben nicht nur ein Laden
Großeinsatz der Feuerwehr am Nachmittag
in Berlin bei einem Wohnhausbrand sind
zwei Menschen ums Leben gekommen das
Feuer war im 12 stock eines Hochhauses
im Bezirk Kreuzberg ausgebrochen zwei
mietersprangen in die Tiefe vor Ort
versuchten Rettungskräfte die beiden zu
reanimieren vergeblich so ein
Feuerwehrsprecher mehrere Personen
wurden gerettet und versorgt das Feuer
ist inzwischen gelöscht
auch wenn es sich gerade nicht so
anfühlt der Juli dürfte weltweit der
wohl heißeste Monat seit Beginn der
Wetteraufzeichnung sein das geht aus
internationalen Daten hervor der
verheerende Trend also über deutlich die
Sommer werden immer heißer mit
gravierenden Folgen
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
will jetzt mit einem nationalen
hitzeschutzplan gegensteuern rittermann
es gibt Gemeinden die sind schon relativ
weit beim Hitzeschutz Straubing in
Niederbayern zum Beispiel Sprühnebel
Anlagen schattenwinkel
Trinkwasserbrunnen um Bürgerinnen und
Bürger vor extremen Temperaturen zu
schützen Hitze kann tödlich sein diese
Plakate sollen künftig in Pflegeheim und
Kliniken warnen solche Leitfäden gibt es
aber häufig schon Verbände fordern
Klimaanlagen in Pflegeeinrichtungen
Gebäude Hitze festmachen im Gespräch sei
vieles sagt lauterbach
wir haben das Ziel die Zahl der
Sterbefälle in diesem Jahr so halbieren
also unter 4.000 zu halten im letzten
Jahr sind 8000 Menschen damit zu Tod
gestorben
hitzewarnstufen gekoppelt an ganz
bestimmte Schutzmaßnahmen wie etwa in
Frankreich schon seit 2003 gibt es
hierzulande bundesweit noch nicht
gefährdete Menschen mit Vorerkrankungen
auch steigt die Gefahr von Herzinfarkt
und Schlaganfällen besonders Hausärzte
müssten aufklären viele Medikamente
wirken bei Hitze häufig anders auch die
richtige Lagerung sehr wichtig du hast
die und die Medikamente bitte denkt zum
Beispiel dran deinen Insulinpen wenn du
den in der Hitze benutzt auch in der
Kühlbox zu haben die Bundesregierung ist
mit ihren Plänen spät dran schließlich
ist schon Ende Juli und der nationale
hitzeschutzplan steckt noch in den
Anfängen
er ist ein großer der deutschen
nachkriegsliteraturen hat bis ins hohe
Alter politische und gesellschaftliche
Debatten angeschoben der Schriftsteller
Martin Walser ist jetzt mit 96 Jahren in
seiner Heimat am Bodensee gestorben
besonders bekannt sind seine Romane ein
fliehendes Pferd oder Tod eines
Kritikers Claudio Armbruster erinnert an
den streitbaren Denker
das sogenannte Leben ist schon ein Roman
muss man sich nicht
scheuen ihn aufzuschreiben
er hat ihn aufgeschrieben unermüdlich
seinen Lebensroman jetzt ist er zu Ende
Martin Walser gestorben und geboren am
Bodensee vier Töchter hat er und einen
Sohn und ein sehr bewegtes Leben er
begann als Rundfunk Redakteur dann erst
Finger anzuschreiben sein erster Roman
Ehen in Philippsburg da war er 30 was in
Erinnerung bleibt neben seinen Büchern
der politisierer Walzer der provozierte
und sich provozieren ließ der schwankte
zwischen ganz links und ganz rechts
einer der größten Skandale der
Bundesrepublik seine Paulskirche Rede 19
Auschwitz eignet sich nicht dafür
dorotine zu werden jederzeit
einsetzbares einschüchterungsmittel oder
Moralkeule geistige Brandstiftung warf
in der Zentralrat der Juden vor viel
später erst bezeichnete Walser diese
Rede als seinen schlimmsten Fehler und
sein größtes Trauma bleibt im Gedächtnis
der Verriss seines Romans jenseits der
Liebe jenseits der Literatur urteilte
Marcel Reich ranitzki kurz nach dieser
Kritik schrieb Walzer ein fliehen des
Pferd seinen größten Erfolg und danach
immer weiter fast jedes Jahr ein Buch
schreiben ist das einzige was das Leben
sozusagen
erträglich macht die Wörter und die
Worte waren sein Schwert und seine Liebe
ein Leben lang
wir machen jetzt sportlich weiter Katja
in aller Munde sind gerade die European
openvisiert heißen in Hamburg und damit
geht es jetzt los so geht's los genau
Daniel Altmaier hat seinen Viertelfinale
heute leider verloren anders als
Alexander Zverev der gegen den Franzosen
Luca waren Asche 634 gewann und im
Halbfinale steht und sogar Endspiel hat
es die Hamburgerin Nummer geschafft nach
einem zwei Satz sie gegen die Russin
Diana Schneider
erst nach getaner Arbeit lächelt sie
dann aber ohne Ende Nummer nur akuguay
19 Jahre bezaubert das Hamburger
Publikum mit einer Wildcard gestartet
zeigt sie im Duell der Teenager wenig
Nervosität und viel Gefühl dieser
stopp-ball aus der Bedrängnis heraus nur
ein Beleg für die Vielseitigkeit der
Lokalmatadorin nach 6:3 im ersten Satz
dominiert sie auch den zweiten mit 6:3
verwandelt ihren zweiten Matchball
diesmal mit einer krachenden Rückhand
die Traumreise geht weiter morgen im
Endspiel wartet die Niederländerin
arancerus auf das Juwel namens Nummer
Akku
sollte man sich merken zur Fußball-WM
der Frauen dort steht übermorgen das
nächste Gruppenspiel für Deutschland an
in Sydney geht es gegen Kolumbien und
Bundestrainerin Martina for Tecklenburg
wird bis dahin noch ein bisschen über
die Taktik nachdenken müssen denn in der
Viererkette fällt Felicitas auch
verletzungsbedingt aus
die letzten Vorbereitungen bei
Deutschland Fußball Frauen sind nicht
unfallfrei gelaufen im Training heute
hat sich Linksverteidigerin Felicitas
raucht das rechte Knie verstaucht und
fällt auf unbestimmte Zeit aus anders
als Jule Brand die sich fit
zurückgemeldet hat gegen Kolumbien
geht's auch darum Linda Casino zu
stoppen die 18-Jährige wird nicht erst
seit dem 2:0 gegen südkoreal als
Wunderkind gefeiert
[Applaus]
der offens Schülerinnen die auch in
diesem Jahr schon in verschiedenen
Turnieren ihre Akzente setzen konnte von
daher gilt darauf zu achten klingt und
sie zu Hause als ob sich die DFB-Frauen
schon auf einen heißen Tanz eingestellt
haben
ja und hier noch die Ergebnisse der
Fußball-WM von heute Argentinien und
Südafrika spielen zwei zu zwei China
gewinnt 1:0 gegen Haiti und England
schlägt Dänemark durch dieses
wunderschöne Tor von Lauren James in der
6 Minute getrübt wurde der Sieg der
Europameisterinnen allerdings durch die
Verletzung von schlüsselspielerin Kira
Walch sie hatte sich ohne
Fremdeinwirkung am Knie verletzt und
musste vom Platz getragen werden
Diagnose bislang noch ausstehend ob sie
Dienstag wieder auf dem Platz steht
gegen China äußerst ungewiss dann vielen
Dank Katja und wir schauen jetzt noch
mal wie Irland an seine große
Popsängerin chinat O'Connor erinnert
ihre Stimme und dieses eine Lied von ihr
einfach unvergesslich sein für die
Ewigkeit an einer Brücke
in Dublin
[Musik]
ja bleibt einfach ein großer Song er
sommerlich ungemütlich bleibt das Wetter
mehr gleich von Christa Orden
afd-parteichef krupala ab 22 Uhr im
heute-journal Interview mit Dunja Hayali
schönen Dank und gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend ja auch morgen brauchen wir
wieder eher den Regen als den
Sonnenschirm die Tiefs hier aus dem
Norden die bringen uns eine klassische
wechselhafte Westwetterlage zwar wird es
morgen hinter dieser Warmfront hier noch
mal eine Spur milder aber das bringt uns
auch feuchte Luft und damit sind Schauer
und kräftige Gewitter für alle möglich
heute Nacht sinken die Werte nur auf 17
bis 13 Grad das hängt auch damit
zusammen das meist bewölkt ist heute
Nacht die Schauer und Gewitter im Norden
lassen schnell nach die schaue und
Gewitter im Süden die gibt's noch länger
die ziehen dann nach Osten ab aber schon
am Morgen erreichen uns im Westen und im
Südwesten neue Schauer und Gewitter
teils auch schon mit Starkregen und die
breiten sich dann morgen im Tagesverlauf
bis in den Osten aus es kommen aber
immer wieder neue Schauer und Gewitter
nach so dass dann vor allem nachmittags
auch in der Mitte und im Süden Lokal mal
Unwetter mit dabei sein können mit
Starkregen und Sturmböen auch der Wind
ist frisch aus westlichen Richtungen die
Sonne sehen will häufig nur
zwischendurch je nach sonnenein
Strahlung erreichen wir 20 Grad an den
Küsten und auch in der Eifel und
immerhin 26 Grad in der Niederlausitz
und im Süden Bayerns am Sonntag wird es
etwas ruhiger da gibt es auch etwas mehr
Sonne aber schon am Montag wird es
wieder kräftig nass es wird auch kühler
als ein Sommer Sonnen hoch ist im Moment
noch nicht in Sicht tschüss